und zu gast bei berlin direkt es jetzt
an dort hofreiter der vorsitzende des
europa ausschusses des deutschen
bundestags herzlich willkommen bei
welchen direkt guten abend herr
hofreiter wir haben heute gehört die
ukraine spricht von
5600 mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen
allein in der region kiew wurden jetzt
schon 1200 leichen gefunden ist putin
nicht längst ein kriegsverbrecher nach
allem was wir wissen ist putin ein
kriegsverbrecher das ist vollkommen
eindeutig und man kann sich schwer
vorstellen dass ein einfach an normalen
umgang wieder mit dem regime putin gibt
ja ist ja auch ein diktator nach innen
geworden ich glaub was jetzt erst mal
neben der feststellung der beweise
notwendig ist es dass er den krieg
verliert und dafür müssen wir schwere
waffen auch an die ukraine liefern das
passiert aber in deutschland nicht
deutschland steht stattdessen
international massiv in der kritik zu
wenig zu spät heißt es warum beschädigt
die ampel
offensichtlich deutschlands ansehen auf
internationalem parkett es ist einiges
geliefert worden aber ich teile die
kritik dass zu wenig und zu spät
geliefert wird und deshalb bin ich der
meinung dass wir zum beispiel marder
panzer dringend an die ukraine liefern
sollte und dass die genehmigungen
beschleunigt werden sollten und dass wir
auch ein energie embargo verhängen
sollten um putin von seinen
finanzquellen abzuschneiden aber sie
kennen doch die handelnden in der ampel
warum wird so wenig geliefert warum
keine schweren waffen
die offizielle begründung ist dass die
bundeswehr keine schweren waffen mehr
hat der rheinmetall stehen nach allem
was ich weiß circa 70 ausgemusterte
marder panzer herum die kann man nicht
sofort liefern die muss man erst
aufarbeiten deshalb ist mein vorschlag
erst mal 20 30 maler panzern aus
bundeswehr beständen die noch
funktionsfähig sind zu liefern und die
ausgemusterten wieder zu ertüchtigen die
ersten 20 30 camper in wenigen wochen
ertüchtigen so dass die bundeswehr nur
ein paar wochen auf ihre maler panzer
verzichten müsste sie sprechen jetzt von
einer offiziellen erklärung
offensichtlich gibt es dann auch eine
andere die andere verstehe ich nicht die
kenne ich nicht und ich versuche so viel
druck wie möglich zu machen dass wir
unsere position da verändern erleben wir
dass immer mehr hochrangige politiker
nach kiew reisen auch als zeichen der
solidarität sollte der bundeskanzler
nicht längst auch seine tasche packen
das ist seine persönliche entscheidung
was ich wichtig finde ist dass wir
unsere politik verändern nämlich am ende
so zu sagen hat die ukraine recht das im
moment vor allem waffen waffen und
nochmal waffen braucht und das nächste
ist dass wir alles tun um putin
abzuschneiden ob er reist oder nicht
dass muss er mit sich selbst ausmachen
aber sie sind vorsitzende des
europa-ausschusses deutschen bundestages
was wäre denn ihre empfehlung auch an
die handelnden deutschen politiker auch
ein frau baerbock
wie gesagt in dem bereich will ich keine
empfehlung ergebnis muss jeder für sich
selbst wissen aber was meine ganz
dringende empfehlung ist was ich auch
erfahre aus allen oder vielen anderen
europäischen länder ist dass wir
deutlich mehr tun dass wir unsere
politik verändern wie schnell müsste
beim thema energie sanktionen jetzt
gehandelt werden beispielsweise beim öl
in meinen augen müsste beim öl innerhalb
der nächsten tage wochen gehandelt
werden innerhalb der nächsten wochen
innerhalb der nächsten wochen mit öl
verdient das system putin am meisten
geld bei öl sind wir nicht zwingend auf
ihn angewiesen in meinen augen auch bei
erdgas nicht er ist hab ich wer generell
für ein generelles in halb energie im
wago innerhalb der nächsten wochen aber
ich kann verstehen dass große sorgen
beim erdgas gibt aber erdöl sollten wir
sehr sehr schnell machen ein wort noch
zur grünen bundesfamilienministerin anne
spiegel die als verantwortliche
umweltministerin auf dem höhepunkt der
flut krise vier wochen in ferien
gefahren ist und jetzt gibt es massive
kritik wehren sie an ihrer stelle jetzt
würden sie zurücktreten wie gesagt ich
halte ehrlich gesagt nichts davon leute
immer nach ihrem persönlichen
verfehlungen zu beurteilen es gab
politiker die einen politischen fehler
nach dem anderen geleistet haben und
vier jahre im amt geblieben sind ich
finde politiker sollten keine heiligen
seien zu sollten vernünftige politik
machen und deshalb sollte der fokus von
kritik immer auf inhaltliche kritik
liegen und deshalb will ich auch nicht
herrn scholz empfehlen wir mit
bestimmten dingen umgehen soll sondern
wünscht man eine andere politik und bei
einem spiegel ich kenne die frau als
mehr als anständig und ich würde mir
wünschen dass sie nach ihrer politik
beurteilt wird und jetzt was sie
persönlich waren sie im urlaub sie haben
aber selbst das wort verfehlung gerade
benutzt das heißt sie sehen ist als
einen schweren fehler an wie gesagt ich
halte nichts davon
ich halte auch nichts davon dass man
kann es so sehr dafür angreift gesagt
man solche leute getreten ich weiß sie
ist zurückgetreten wie gesagt ich halte
davon einfach nichts man sollte leute
nach ihren politischen handlungen
beurteilen nämlich politiker sind auch
keine besseren menschen und wenn man nur
heilige haben wir dann kriegen wir
irgendwann nur noch unfähige politiker
herr hofreiter hat seinen dank für das
gespräch danke ihnen